هو حدث ليس بجديد فيضان في منطقه عانت من
الفيضانات لكنه هذه المره الاسوء بين
اخوته فما واجهته مناطق شرق جنوب افريقيا
في ابريل الماضي كان ماساه كبرى قتلت
المئات وشردت الالاف وتركت صورا تعيسه
ستخلد طويلا فماذا حدث
في الحادي عشر من ابريل للعام 2022 فيما
كانت البلاد في عطله عيد الفصح اجتاحت
العاصفه شبه الاستوائيه عيسى مناطق عده في
مقاطعه كوازولونانتال بجنوب افريقيا
تلقت مدينه ديربان ثالث اكبر مدن البلاد
هطولا مطريا متواصلا في نوبه اعتبرت
الاكثر عنفا مقارنه بنوبات سابقه احدثت
فيضانات خطيره في عامي 2019
طالت الامطار اجزاء واسعه من مقاطعه
كوازولونانتال وخلال 24 ساعه سجلت هطولا
مطريا ما بين 2400 مليمتر تسببت الامطار
الغزيره فيضان انهار امانزم توتي امبيلو
ام جيني كما احدثت انهيارات طينيه مما
تسبب في اضرار ودمار واسع النطاق في
التجمعات السكنيه على طول ضفاف النهر جرفت
المياه عددا كبيرا من المنازل وتضررت
الجسور والطرق ما ادى الى عزل العديد من
قرى وبلدات باكملها كما تعطلت امدادات
المياه والكهرباء
ان جرفت حاويات الشحن في ميناء ديربان
الذي يعد جزءا من سلسله التوريد العالميه
بل انها تحولت الى اكوام من الفوضى مقلوبه
راسا على عقب سجلت حكومه جنوب افريقيا
459 حاله وفاه في الكارثه التي اعتبرت من
اسوا الفيضانات التي شهدتها المنطقه منذ
ما يقرب من ثلاثه عقود
قدر عدد النازحين باربعين الف شخص حاولت
المنظمات الدوليه تقديم المساعدات لهم
وتغطيه الاحتياجات الاكثر الحاحا كالحصول
على الغذاء والمياه النظيفه والرعايه
الاوليه
تشرد اكثر من اربعين الف شخص كما دمر اكثر
من 12 الف منزل بالكامل في الجزء الجنوبي
الشرقي من جنوب افريقيا مع وجود احتياجات
ضخمه لم تستطع الحكومه الاستجابه لها بشكل
كاف ولا سيما في المناطق النائيه
والمعزوله التي تضررت بشده اعلن رئيس
البلاد سرير راما فوزا حاله الكارثه
الوطنيه بعد الكارثه بقي الالاف في ملاجئ
الاخلاء حتى وقت طويل فيما بقي امام
الكثير ممن فقدوا احد افراد اسرتهم او
منازلهم او سبل عيشهم رحله طويله للتعافي
من اثار الكارثه المدمره التي ربطت
اسبابها بتغير المناخ العالمي
[موسيقى]